so we're gonna talk about razor pages he
Nate's been on that core something I'm
super super super super excited about I
said I would never say super excited
when I joined Microsoft but here I am
Stephanie is later and I just said super
excited because I got to work on this
over the past year and a half and we we
are very very happy with where it's
turned out we still have a lot of great
ideas about that make it better but
hopefully by the end of this I can
convince people in here who have to
already dismissed razor pages as a
complete waste of time that maybe it's
at least worth looking at okay at least
worth looking at everyone in here is an
MVC developer I'm assuming all right
okay anyone here web forms developer
even if you used to be a web fonts
developer it's me okay good no problem
at all so what is razor pages so it's a
new page focused approach or mini
framework or not even that a bunch of
stuff in MVC in asp.net core it is not
separate it is part of a speed on that
core MVC it's the same view engine it is
part of razor alright it's not we have
pages that's run by this view engine and
view is run by that view engine it's all
the same stuff like MVC is extremely
malleable and configurable alright for
those of you have ever customized MVC
you will probably know that and in a
spirit core we have this new thing
called application model in MVC which
lets you change lots of the conventions
about NBC without you having to go and
derive from the stuff in the box or
replace it in DI it's actually very nice
we use a lot of that capability to allow
you to write stuff as pages and then we
added a few niceties on top of that that
we think really fall out of building
applications this way it's designed and
focused for people who are doing service
at HTML generation so would you use this
for your web api is obviously not
controls and actions are a great
paradigm for programming web api's well
we think so I mean there are other ones
that are very good too but controls and
actions as where it's at or if you're
returning anything that is an HTML
you're not returning something that's
going to be shown in a browser stick it
in an action and put it on a controller
that's perfect
but if you are returning HTML from your
server that's going to go into a browser
I would thoroughly thoroughly recommend
that you look at razor pages it is not
meant to be like
to PHP right it's not meant to be the
new version of asp.net web pages that
horrible framework that we built four
five six seven years ago okay anyone use
that thing no a couple of hands guys no
one's gonna admit that one that's even
worse than web forms um some good things
came out of that though that's where
razor came from like razor came from
that effort alright so this is not that
we're not trying to show you your
Creator generation of developers I'll
tell you not to use CS proj and tell you
not to do dependency injection and all
that I will not be able to write
unittest
right all those things are encouraged
and possible and first-class citizens on
top of razor pages right it's just MVC
and it's not just for simple scenarios
don't think of this is like oh this will
be great when I just have a very simple
page that does blah know it's designed
to handle all scenarios for when you're
doing server-side HTML in general okay
if you're doing it with MVC and views
today you should be able to do with
razor pages and it should be better and
if it's not I want to hear the feedback
and if it's objective not subjective
then we'll try and make some
improvements to fix those issues you can
integrate it with controllers and views
so if you are migrating or you have a
large code base and you don't want to go
and convert or your controllers actions
and views over to razor pages but you
like razor pages you can reuse the razor
parts all right so you can say common
layout file used by both my pages and my
views or comments enter partials and
those are used by both my pages and my
views okay
it's just razor that's all it is it's
nothing particularly special except that
we've added some new stuff that's nice
and all the conventions that I'm going
to show there's a lot of conventions
over configuration in here but it's not
conventions in spite of configuration or
without configuration you can change
them all all right so what you'll see
out of the box is what we decided we
wanted things to be named and how we
would find things and how we would
dispatch and how we would invoke and
what we would pass in that's what we
chose to do out of the box but you can
change it you can customize it to your
heart's content
just as you can with MVC all right so
don't get too hung up on some of the
terminology I might use if it doesn't
sit well with you you can change it
alright you don't like what we default
in certain places you can change the
defaults I just want to reiterate it is
MVC all this stuff that
pre-existed before razor pages still
exists and you can still use it all in
razor pages okay
routing is obviously still there pages
create routes you put a page file on
disk it results in a route and it's
built on the attribute routing system
the good one not the crappy one all
right models are still there obviously
models are great they allow us to
separate our concerns put things in nice
simple classes that we can pass around
that's what models are for action
descriptors is really the heart of NBC
NBC doesn't care about the sea right the
actual framework doesn't really care
that you have controllers all it cares
about is there's a method that's an
action that they can invoke and then
it's mapped to some incoming function
some incoming request sorry via routing
that's it and everything else is just
sugar on top of that all right so action
descriptors come out of whether you're
building controllers and actions or
pages and handlers it's the same thing
everything gets dispatched for an action
descriptor in MVC that also means you
get action results what happens after
you execute an action you get a result
right and that runs back through the
other way of the MVC pipeline pages are
exactly the same
you can return action results from pages
if you so wish obviously there are some
new action results ones that rendered
the page ones that redirect pages etc
etc you can return the existing ones if
you really wanted to you can return a
view from a page I don't know why you
would but you could you can return Jason
maybe that's a good idea
maybe it's not I'm not gonna judge you
you get filters so you can do
cross-cutting concerns the normal
filters that you'd expect work there is
a new filter a page filter that you can
apply there only runs and pages as well
you get model binding of course you get
value providers to support model binding
of course it's the same view context
object that you've always used there is
a derived page context as well but the
view context is still there with all the
same data that you've ever had that also
means you get the same tempted
you get support for tag helpers which
are obviously fantastic if you don't
like tag helpers for some weird reason
you can still use HTML helpers they just
work layout some partials obviously
still work and anyone using view
components from a street called 1x
anyone done that ok couple of hands not
many people have use those yet but they
still work alright so if you factored
out some logic into a view component I'm
just kind of like a mini controller that
you invoke from views you can call those
as well from your pages alright and
that's the end of my slides I think
there's any more slides
oh there all right let's just look at
raisa pages in so I have a project here
that I created I will say the Razr pages
projects now are the default alright so
if you weren't in my previous talk I
mentioned this briefly if I go over here
and do a file new if you're in vs and I
choose a spinet called web application
and I'm choosing to oh this template is
the Razr pages template okay if you
don't want to use razor pages for your
HTML you would choose this one it says
model-view-controller this gives you all
the same UI and identity all the same
functionality the three pages that's web
stuff as this one but it's done
using MVC Model View controller instead
of using razor pages okay so we feel
that strongly about it that we want
people to use it by default so I've
already done that over on this one here
I'll make sure I get runs because I
probably changed it and broke it because
I usually do accidentally let's run that
up do do your Facebook is like spamming
me alright so there's my page it looks
very similar to what you would have seen
in your template before how do we add a
new page well what does the structure
look like I have a pages folder again by
default if you don't like it you can
change it that's fine we just decided
that for good organization like we do in
most of our unit core applications that
we demonstrate and that we encourage
people to do we have a separate folder
to put our stuff in so we don't have our
controllers folder with the views folder
and the models folder to do basic HTML
or just to get HTML at all you just
stick stuff in here why do I have a
controllers folder as well well because
this application because it has off has
an endpoint that doesn't return HTML as
I mentioned and so it has a controller
with a logout link so when you click
logout we sign you out do some logging
and then we redirect you back to the
home page that's all the only reason we
have a controller so we have an endpoint
to do that okay everything else is in
the pages folder well how did I
configure this in my app it doesn't look
any different
where's MVC there it is
adding NVC adds raiser pages because
razor pages is part of NBC's normal view
engine if you add the razor view engine
you get razor pages it's as simple as
that
okay this method just adds the options
so if you want to configure something
about razor pages you do it in this
method here now in this template because
we've got off and identity and stuff set
up
we're configuring some authorization
requirements for certain aspects of the
folder so because everything in razor
pages is folder based and file based
because it's a page based framework
everything becomes quite a lot simpler
when it comes to organizing so this is
my pages route by default and then
inside here I have my razor files my
index is going to default so if I make a
request to the root of this application
it's going to serve index CC HTML right
straightforward it's going to use layout
CSS HTML because that's been set up in V
start and it's going to use view imports
just like it would if you're using MVC's
and views and everything else is very
very standard and should be nothing new
to people who have done razor and views
before how do we add a new page well
that's pretty straightforward I can add
a new item let me add a new razor page
which is here we'll call it demo Sydney
there is a bug in vs at the moment where
when you add a new razor page I hope to
get fixed very soon the intellisense
doesn't work so you have to close and
reopen it which is a little annoying and
then inside here it's just razor right
so I can say hello from Sydney nothing
is particularly new there I can run this
we'll go back to the application
I can go now to demo Sydney application
is recompiling because I had touched one
of the CSV files and I've got my hello
from Sydney page up and running okay
super super super simple now obviously
we don't just put all of our logic or
all of our stuff in a page inside here
we have other ways that we can do so you
can see the model directive is being
used up here to specify what we call a
page model so let me go and have a look
at that demo Sydney model and let me
show you where that is on disk so some
of you eagle-eyed viewers may
have already noticed the file name here
demo Sydney dot cease HTML dot CS so if
I go over to the solution Explorer again
under demo Sydney if I expand that you
can see I've got my demo Sydney dot C is
HTML de CS now it's just a naming
convention all right yes default the
aspx dot CS is back it's just a naming
convention all right it's not derivation
right it is not merging together with a
code beside file like we had in Asia I'm
using all the turns from web forms
because I did that stuff for 15 years it
is not that this is a page model that is
attached to the page okay the page model
know of the page knows about the page
model okay
the page model doesn't have access to
anything on the page it's no different
to a controller being able to return a
view but not being able to dive into it
it can just pass data into it okay and
you use the model to talk back and forth
this is much more like an mvvm system so
who's ever used an mvvm framework like
zamel or Zama okay or angular even
angular or react those type of systems
where your model your view model isn't
just a poco generally has functionality
on it you call methods on it you bind
from UI events to methods that are on
your view model okay and it's live and
interactive but still separated you can
still test them alright nothing wrong
being able to test those things what web
forms got wrong was a lot of stuff but
primarily it really wasn't very testable
because things weren't really separated
well you had a code behind and the view
part that aspx file derived from the
code behind but that was kind of
problematic right then you often have
this designer file that was hidden as
well and that kind of got merged into
the code behind and the front-end
derived from that and that made
everything kind of a big bowl of mess
like we separated two things in
different files but conceptually and
architectural II they weren't separate
concerns which made it very difficult to
test and then you didn't have dependency
injection the things that were on there
the properties weren't settable right
you couldn't lock in a thing so like it
really wasn't set up in such a way to
make it useful all those things aren't
true of this nothing derives from this
you get a page model class you make your
model on top of that then you attach the
page to it and then you put handlers on
here they get executed
certain reports come in so you can
probably guess by the name of this
handler when it's going to execute so
when a get request comes in this will
happen so let's pass some data from our
page model back to our page well how do
we do that well in a view and an MVC
controller what we do you would create a
separate model class generally and you
would new that up you'd set some
properties on it then you'd pass that to
the view result right or you would do
the abdominal thing and you would put
stuff in View data and then you were
just like hope it ends up on the other
side you'd pull it out by a string key
right no one does that because it's
horrible we only do that when we have to
pass data between views because there's
really no other way to do it but in here
we have a much better way I can it add a
property so this is my message all right
and then when get comes in I can say
message is equal to hello Sydney and I
could do whatever I want in there
obviously and then rather than hello
from Sydney now I'll just say at model
dock message all right so if I go back
to my up now and hit a five I should see
the exact same thing I saw before it's
just that now I'm setting this message
from code rather than being hard-coded
in the view right and I really should
prove that shouldn't I so I should
probably come back here and say hello
from and I'll do something like this and
I'll prove that it's coming from here
name of demo Sydney model alright then
we'll come back here five wait for that
to recompile zoom it up a bit and then
we'll see it's actually coming from the
model now so already you should see that
the separation that we're doing here
still exists like the type of operation
you're used to with views and
controllers is still here there's still
a formal way to pass data from one side
to the other it's just that it's just
easier right you just add a property and
you code it as if it was an active view
model just like you would do in the name
vvm system now this is one way I'm
setting stuff from here onto this
property and then when the page runs it
can read stuff from here alright that
makes sense because unlike an mvvm
system where you have an active UI this
just last for the cycle of one request
and gets sent down as HTML right but we
also want to support binding stuff on
the way in obviously right so we'll look
at doing some of that stuff as well all
right so I already have
a model type up here in my data I have a
customer object and inside here it's
pretty standard first name last name
email phone number blade a better barber
that I've got some data annotations on
here so let's build a fairly simple crud
sort of view here but we'll do it using
razor pages instead of MVC all right
actually I might just tweak my I'm gonna
freak out the AV guy cuz I just want to
tweak my resolution I think my monitor
is running at 4k and then it's trying to
scale it down in the a/c that's not good
let's do this and just watch everything
explode that should be better I'm hoping
that this means that my vs yeah hey you
guys not quite as small as it was before
good hopefully I'll zoom in and out
though so we can keep saying all right
so let's close my demo one we don't care
without anymore
let's go off and build some pages to
edit customers so I'm going to create a
folder called customers and I'll put a
page in here I'll make any index dot C
use HTML so what will the URL for that
be any guesses slash customers right
it's in the customers folder because
this is file based when the route is
constructed for this page it's to ride
from go to the page route which in my
app is slash pages because I didn't
change it and then look at the path from
the page route to the file customers
slash index okay so then the URL is
gonna be customers slash index but
because index is a default document
it's just slash customers okay simple as
that now you can change routes as well
and we'll talk about that a little later
you can customize all this stuff so
let's say h1 call this customers okay
make sure that this is working before I
go off and write a bunch of code so
slash customers now in my application I
should see a page that doesn't work
because for some reason v/s decided to
kill Elias Express so we'll just hit
ctrl f5 again
there we go there we go so now I've got
my customers page showing up here all
right so what do we want to do we want
to list out the customers that we have
in this application all right so let's
do that I'm going to create a table and
then inside that table I'll have a tea
head and then inside that tea aired I'm
gonna have a few I'm gonna have a row
and inside that I'll have a tea head
that does thing and I'll do HTML dot
display name for and why my only display
name for I don't have anything yet so
that's a problem so let's go and add
something to my model so that I can
actually start doing things here well
I'm probably gonna need some customers
so I'll say I enumerable of customer I
have a customer class already so that's
good and we'll call it customers all
right very good so now I have some shape
keeping the wrong key there do all right
have some shape let's go back to here so
now I should be able to do customer is
really its play name for model where is
it m such that m dot customers will just
go into will did you do the chip well
yeah what do people usually do I always
argue about this with people because I
don't I'm gonna change that to a
collection cuz indexing into this is
just so much nicer than doing it this
way I'm just going to this way right
first name so do what ID in here
customers dot one give me the first one
please where's my intellisense gone
first name do Oh
touching doesn't isn't an index so I
need to I list haha there we go so I'm
gonna have a that and I'll just copy and
paste this dude it to do will do first
name last name and I think I had birth
date or something here we go will do
birthday very good and then I have to
add a body so I can actually go off and
loop through these which we'll do in
just a moment
lads and cells in here and then we'll do
the normal thing that we would do here
as well HTML dot display for and we'll
do am such that well I'm gonna do a for
loop now so we'll do customer will put
our for loop in at for each customer in
modeled customers
[Music]
okay up and then we'll finish this one
out I'm to say display for EM such that
because we don't really want to use em
but we'll do customer dot first name and
then we will copy and paste all of that
okay and we'll make this one last name
which it should be this one up here as
well I've just noticed and we'll do
birthday okay now I don't have any data
yet so I don't think this is actually
gonna work particularly well um this
obviously has to be in a row as well
which is why the editor is screaming at
me right now all right
that's probably the bare minimum I would
have to do right to get something to
work let's see what the page does I
don't have anything yet so I'm just
gonna assume it's gonna do nothing and
it throws a massive exception because I
haven't set customers to a value right
null ref so let's do that let's go and
add a constructor and oh and we'll get
an exception from the editor that's
awesome let's just not trust it and
reopen it to make sure that's fine and
then I'll get my application dbcontext
I'll scroll that away dependency
injection just works the same way and a
razor page as it does in anything else
in a screen it called its activate to
take it in by the constructor and then
use it down here and your own game
alright so I'm gonna have to set
customers I want to make this a sync
because you know that's what we should
be doing these days so async task we'll
call it on get async you don't have to
it doesn't matter if it has a you think
on the N&R it's just a convention we
just support both right if you don't
like the word a sink on the Indy Racing
methods it's fine we'll still call it
so we'll do customers yeah we'll just do
to list async we'll bring in EF to do
that so I will set customers equal to
underscore DB dot customers to link it
to lists a sink let me bring in EF to
make that work obviously I have to await
that all right so now I should at least
have something on my customers object so
I might throw but I'm assuming it's not
gonna do anything cuz I haven't had any
customers yet so we'll go off and we'll
add the ability to add customers next or
we'll add some logic so there's nothing
there
get a table that's not particularly
useful it's not very pretty either so
let's just quickly tell bootstrap that I
really want that to be a data table
there we go that's a bit better and I'll
add a condition up here if model dot
customers dot count is greater than zero
do that otherwise we'll show something
else
now we'll do maybe a P tag and no
customers found try that all right so
now says no customers found I don't
particularly like having this much code
I thought a lot of code right but I
don't particularly having that much code
so I'm gonna do what I would normally do
an mvvm system and I'll do something
like prop bull has customers and then
I'll make that a derived or a calculated
property which is customers count it's
greater than zero all right and then
I'll just change this to say if it has
customers all right okay and it should
just keep working the same way no
customers found so we're gonna have to
add the ability to create a customer so
we'll do that next
there we go so let's add a button down
here so we can create customers so we'll
do a button and we'll say that has to go
to a page called new I guess doesn't
exist yet
create new customer all right and we'll
give that a class or bootstrap makes it
look pretty
BTN BTN default does that look like
okay so now I can create a new customer
but the button doesn't know anything
because I asked it to generate me a URL
for a page that doesn't exist all right
so URL generation in pages is routing
it's no different absolutely no
different so I've said please give me a
URL for the page called new it doesn't
exist for adding Caesar and I'll just
give you a URL for the root of the
application so that's what it did so
let's go and create our new page so back
over to customers we'll add a new item
razor page we'll call it new so now I
can build my new customer page so let's
go and open that up again I'll add an h1
in here create customer let's see if
that's working so I'm gonna hit f5 to
get the app to recompile
I mean I said that recompile quicker
we're working on it it is quicker than
it was in 1x but it still takes about
105 seconds okay and your customers
still didn't go anywhere because I made
it a button rather than a link that was
silly of me let's change that to an
anchor tag there we go so now I'm off to
my create customer page so let's add the
UI that we'll need to go ahead and
create a customer so let's do that so
I'm going to want to form method is
going to be post
all right so form tag helper now in a
spinet core to always runs if you don't
have any attributes on it telling it
where to go it just assumes that you're
going back to where you are because
that's what you do when you're
programming pages alright so there's
just been little slight changes made to
some of the tag helpers in the system
based on some of the idiomatic sort of
patterns that we found when building
these types of applications rather than
do this one from scratch
I might just copy this one from an
existing one so let me very quickly go
and find that so you don't have to watch
me type out every single form field
because that's a little laborious so
over here don't do that
customers new let me grab that no this
is nice it has titles and all types of
stuff I'll pinch that I'll pinch that
bit at least all right okay so what I do
I add a link that takes me back to the
customer list so you know ASP page back
to index that's fine then I've got some
bootstrap stuff in there and then a
whole bunch of form stuff set up to edit
the form I've got no code behind yet so
I'll know page model sorry so none of
this stuff is lighting up so let's go
and add the properties that we'll need
to the page model so I never gate to
that let me add a customer property
that's what we'll use to track the
customer I'm actually working on not
customer and this time because I want
the customer to be bound on post I have
to actually tell razor pages to bind
this property when it's coming in all
right so I decorate it with buying
property this is a new attribute in a
spinet core - and it
works on pages and controllers so if you
want to have properties on your
controllers or page models that get
bound on post or post like requests you
can decorate them in buying property and
they'll automatically get bound okay now
you can also have stuff just come
through in methods just like you
normally would so I can do bode public
void on post okay and I could take in
here if I wanted to anything I can take
a customer and customer will get bound
as part of the post handler running okay
but I'm gonna use just a property
because I need the property anyway in
order to be able to call these tag
helpers and have the whole you know
runtime scaffolding system generate the
right HTML for me so I'm gonna do that
well I don't really have to do anything
on get in this page because this is a
create page there's nothing I have to
look up so let's do on post instead this
will likely be async again because they
almost always are let's do that and then
let's look at the code that we have to
do here so again this is all pretty
bog-standard
so EF stuff so let's go and add or copy
this I'll just override the constructor
name alright so there's my database so
what are we going to do well first thing
we'll do we'll say if the not model
state dot is valid what would we do if
the model state is not valid normally
well we'd probably re-render the view
right so I'm just going to return page
okay that just renders the page that's
associated with this page model okay now
I haven't actually set a return type so
I'm gonna have to do that well it's the
same one reaction result okay
nothing special you're probably noticing
that it's actually not a lot of work to
move code from controllers and views
into a razor page and vice versa
alright because all the primitives are
basically the same it's just the
patterns and the conventions for method
names and dispatching are more tailored
to the type of files that you're putting
them in that's it all the conventions
all the types are the same alright so
then what would I do I have a valid one
well then I'm probably going to want to
go off and save it so let's go wait
DB dot customers to add and we'll add my
new customer which is the customer
property good probably want to not that
one silly let's say if changes isn't it
then we'll save that a wait
DB dot Save Changes async now if I was
being really good I'd probably put a
try-catch around this and I'd handle DB
concurrency Bloodgood update exception
all the rest of it but this is a demo so
I'm not gonna bother so what I want to
do after I've successfully changed it
though is what I don't want to render
the page because then I'm violating post
redirect get right I want to redirect
somewhere so I could either just
redirect back to this page but that's
kind of weird cuz this is the crepe form
I probably want to redirect back to the
list page so let me return the result of
a redirect to that page so I'll say
redirect a page and I'll just say index
now for those who have been looking at
these page names I've been passable
passing in and wondering how this works
when we do URL generation for pages we
support relativity okay so this is a
relative page referral I didn't put a
slash at the beginning so that's going
to look for an index page that's
relative to the current page I'm on and
that's kind of important we don't have
anywhere else in MVC where this really
makes sense but it makes sense in pages
because you have a folder with pages in
it right you can just do that type of
stuff cuz we look at the file system or
the metadata about the pages once they
compiled if I were to put a slash in
front of this this would go to the root
of the site and go to its index page and
if I did a dot slash that would be the
same as just omitting it completely
because that's a relative one you can
also check you can do traversal all that
type of stuff well what's the advantage
of that it means that once I have a
folder full of customer stuff I can take
that customer folder and move it
anywhere else and it'll continue to work
in relation to itself right because all
the links are relative that's kind of
the advantage of doing HTML focused page
programming right whereas if all of this
was in controllers often when you make a
routing change you have to go and find
all the references to that route
throughout the site and then unless
they're named routes in which case you
refer to them by name and but not many
people I know go to the trouble of
setting up named routes for every single
endpoint in their app um so you have to
go and refactor it so this is just a
nice little thing that we're able to do
because we're working with page files
all right so let's see if this worked I
should I think unless I miss something
now have the ability to create a
customer let's have a look
all right so I have a form that's good
so let me create myself all right now
they are actually let's see validation
work so I have validations working so I
rendered the client-side validation so
everything so far is good and then I'll
hit save stuff seems to be happening and
it's saved great so I have a record now
in my database which is awesome but I
kind of like to see a little bit more
feedback when things happen so I want to
add a success message to this page when
someone creates a new customer so let's
go ahead and do that well how would I do
that because I'm redirecting across
pages this gets a little complicated
right yes yeah yes correct
that wasn't a razor pages thing so the
question is here it's specifically right
this is a feature of the tag helper
system which has been there phrase
phonetic or since version 1 this
property on the tag helper ASP 4 is of
type model expression and model
expression is a very special tag helper
type that is built for tag helpers that
says I want the value of this HTML
attribute to point to something on the
model all right so when we code Jen this
we kind of prefix this with model for
you and the editor knows that so when we
built the tooling we do that for you as
well and of course the advantage of that
is because we have intellisense so I can
come in here and hit ctrl J and the only
Intel a sense I get is the stuff on my
model which is really nice
ok all right so let's go and add
feedback now it's a little it's a little
can get a little complicated right
because I'm actually redirecting so if I
want to set a message here that's going
to show on this page well how do I do
that how do I pass that from this page
through the redirect to the browser and
back to the server again what would
people usually do so I think in the
templates we used to have an enum that
was defined somewhere in the app with
the different messages and then we'd
have like we passed the enum index
through the query string and then we
would use the query string to binder the
enum to set the message in the move end
of that message which sucks and then the
problem with that would be that if you
hit f5 and the browser after the first
one the career string stays there so you
just see the message every single time
which is not really what you
you could try and saw it in session you
know that's not very nice
you could use temp data but that
requires session so that's not very much
nicer either you can put in a cookie but
then you'd really have to worry about
securing it making sure that the cookie
value was signed by you so you don't
open a vector where someone can put a
message in the cookie and then have a go
to your server and then they you show it
right you don't want to do they don't
allow unvalidated content so we built a
feature to make this really really
really easy so all I have to do is add a
property string message okay I'll set
that property where I want it to be set
where it's logical to set it I just
perform the operation customer created
successfully so I have all the states
about the operation if I wanted to put
in the the ID or the name or anything I
could do all that here because I have
all the state right I'm right in that
method all right then all I need to do
is go over to my index create ass
matching property with the same name
string message and I just have to
decorate them both with an attribute
that tells raisa pages where you want
that properties backing value to be
stored and incidentally this works in
controllers now as well
all right so every time we found
something as part of doing this that we
felt was a good pattern for doing HTML
based stuff we said well let's set it to
raise the pages and then we'll figure
out whether it makes sense in MVC
as well and if it does we add it there
as well okay so now all I have to do is
set this property and read it on any
page model or controller where it has
that name and it will always be backed
by the same backing field so for those
who don't know temp data works like this
when you set the value of a temp data
with a given key it stays valid for the
current user no matter how many requests
they make until you read it again and
then when you read it we delete it
all right does that make sense so it's
not just one request it's as many
requests until it's read again using the
same key all right now before temp data
had to be set up using session and
setting up session was always a pain cuz
you have to have read err so you had to
have in memory session or something like
that we
change the default template a provider
in 202 use cookies so we encrypt the
cookie then we sign the cookie with all
your temp data in it goes down to the
client goes back to the server as soon
as you've read it we delete the cookie
so it only lasts as long as your temp
data value lasts ok so now I have to
display it I guess I'm actually
displaying it anywhere am I let me let
me cheat I know I have a nice little
sort of alert thing somewhere or I could
just cheat from taking the other one I
guess couldn't I if I go over to edit no
I think I have it on this one here we go
this is what I want perfect
I'm gonna add a little bit of logic to
the top of my index page now and I'm
gonna add a helper property that derive
that calculates whether I should show
the message or not and you can probably
figure out how that's going to work
it'll be a bull it'll say show message
and that will be set to true based on
whether the string has a value okay now
again anyone who's ever built built mvvm
style systems zamel any of those so this
is pretty common like your model has a
whole bunch of helper properties that
are read-only that your view just kind
of like asks ball strings data only
cared I want a lot of logic just tell me
what to do so you put all this logic in
your model so you can test it it's
really really easy to test it when it's
here right and it keeps all the logic in
one place which I really really like
alright so now I have enough that
hopefully if I do this again I'll get a
nice little message so let's do that
it says hit f5 to force the app to
recompile then I will go ahead and I
will create my second customer and I saw
Jordan before so I will create a
customer called Jordan Knight look at
that now I get customer crater
successfully at the top of the page all
I did I'd have to worry about where the
data was going enough to pass off the
crew string set a property here read the
property there but back them both with
temp data and it all just works okay
really really really nice if I hit f5 I
show you by clicking it it goes away
because the temp data is now gone okay
now if you want to see all that
happening under the covers you can
obviously use the network tab hit
preserve log go over to create customer
create another one let me turn that let
me turn it on let me clear this out and
we can do
like Joe Blow come down here it hit save
and then down in here what you'll see is
when I do the new when the header comes
back we're setting this cookie there it
is NBC core cookie temp data provider
which includes a large crypto string
which trust me it includes the message
that I just wrote and then I get a
redirect right to 302 so then I get a
redirect and then I get a get back to
the customers page of slash customers
which is my index that request sent up
that cookie so let me find the request
here there it is so I've got a nanny for
a cookie and then all the way over here
somewhere there will be my temp data
cookie there it is
so I sent up the temp data cookie
awesome but then in the response headers
for that same request you'll see we're
clearing that cookie okay set cookie
temp data provider and that expired at
the beginning of the JavaScript epoch
which was in 1970 alright so that's how
it is that we get this very simple way
of passing simple data
don't put complex objects in here please
just put strings and balls and dates and
things like that in there between pages
or controllers very very very simply so
that's really really nice including
across redirects right so let's have the
ability to delete all right we've got
create but we need to be able to purge
so let's do that let me go in add a
button so I'll add an extra column in
the head here and I'll put a
non-breaking space in it because I'm
old-school
I don't trust browsers to render the
right thing so I'll put a thing in here
and we'll put a button in here and we'll
make that button say delete and I'll
give that button some class and we'll
say BTN BTN extra small and we'll do BTN
danger because I'm going to delete when
I click on it and we want that button to
go somewhere that will do the delete
right well I don't have a form yet so
I'd best wrap the whole thing in a form
now so let's do method equals post and
we'll stick that underneath here okay do
I dare invoke formatting no don't trust
formatting in a razor document that's
not a good idea
I get meds told me that's Kristensen he
told me that they're rewriting all the
formatting for the HTML editor in the
next version which I was very happy
about to make it less smart and that
will basically mean it always does the
right thing won't try and figure out we
just indent every time I see something
new all just indent simple simple simple
so I'm hoping that's gonna solve all of
our razor formatting woes that we've
been dealing with for the last on eight
years since we build the razor editor
all right so I got a delete button now
but it doesn't go anywhere so let's say
I want this deep delete button to go
well where well I don't really want a
separate delete page I'm not gonna build
like a delete confirmation I'm just
going to assume that you do know what
you're doing when you hit delete so I
just kind of want to stay on this page
you hit delete it deletes it that shows
a message okay and I don't have to put
it in a separate controller or a
separate page I just wanted to be on a
different method on this page so I'm
gonna specify a custom Handler so we'll
do a SB page Handler and we'll say I
want this when it clicked to run the
delete Handler
well how does that work well I'm in a
form which I didn't specify an action
for so the action has already been set
to this page but then when I set page
handler on the button this renders out
using form action alright which is an
html5 attribute that lets buttons inside
forms change the action of the form when
you click them so you can have multiple
buttons that go to different end points
inside a single form rather than having
to have a separate form for every single
button yeah it's nice so we do that for
you as part of this incidentally if I
set there to ASP - controller it does
the same thing all right it'll just
render form actions and you can go off
to a different place for that I mean
have a separate form so let's add that
handler so it actually does something so
I'm gonna add a handler public async
task on post delete async so how does
that work while it's still on it's still
post because it's handling the post verb
but now I've added a suffix which is the
handler name okay delete delete' is my
handler so this one will get this one
will happen when I do it late now I want
to pass in the ID of the thing to delete
right so I'll do ID and I better make
sure I actually pass it in here well how
do I do that I do it via routing that's
how you pass stuff around in links so
I'll do route ID and this
we'll have to be customer dot ID all
right so now when the URL is built that
sets the form action it'll take into
consideration handler and it'll take
into consideration all the route de
drive past it and I should get a lovely
long link that eventually ends up in it
posting to this one here with some data
so let's go ahead and delete it
what's the easiest way to delete using
EF I usually do the hacky way so I do
EF dot customers dots attached and then
I do a new customer and I set its ID to
ID and I do it in I do that and then I
said it's state equal to the deleted
state alright so you can do this
multiple race right you could read it
from the database first see if it's
there and if it's there marketers check
but I don't wanna do two database reads
I'm just gonna tell it believe this
thing right simple then I'll wait the
changes save changes they sync I'm
assume that's always going to work and
then I will go ahead and redirect again
I don't want to just render the page
I've performed a post I need to make
sure I redirect back to the page right
it's a redirect return to whoops
redirect to page and if you just pass
redirector page no arguments it will
assume you want to go to the current
page super straightforward okay
lastly helps if you actually return my
action result I want to set a message so
I'll say message is equal to customer
deleted successfully and this is the
same message field that I added to
support the message coming from the
other page but I'm just using it to
support the message from itself okay so
it's a property all it is in this code
is just a string property that you set
and then the framework is taking care of
actually populating it and traversing it
across pages and redirects and all that
type of stuff all right so let's see if
this works
recompiling we compiling we compiling
hopefully I know I'm gonna get a delete
link good all right well I might
actually debug this one let's put a
breakpoint here it's attached to dotnet
very good come over here hit delete good
alright so it hit excellent
there's my ID seven double O to go ahead
and delete that
good set my thing redirect come back to
the browser and it's gone and the
customer has been deleted successfully
marvelous very very nice I think very
straightforward and quite a few less
files in order to achieve the same thing
as in NBC with all the same levels of
separation now what URL got posted to
there we didn't see it right because it
happens super super quick so if I delete
Jordan it says gone like I don't really
get to see the URL so we have to go down
into here and have a look at what
happened so I got the customers well I
didn't preserve cat logs that's not
gonna do much let's delete myself I'll
clear this out I'll Joe Blow already
believe myself hit delete there we go so
I went to this URL here my mouse keeps
falling down so ID equals blah and
handler equals delete alright because we
didn't tell routing where to put ID and
we didn't tell it where to put handler
right there's no route declaration for
this page it's just a page name and so
all it could do was add them as query
strings that's what routing always does
if you say there were two routing here's
the route I want you to use and here's
the route data or what you use to
construct the URL if there's no matching
tokens it just shoves it all on the end
of the query string right that's how
it's always work if you want to change
this though because you don't like the
fact I'm passing all this is at the
query string it's really really really
easy so let's do that let's change the
URL come back to my index page come back
up to my page declaration and what you
can do up here is you can specify extra
route segments to add after the page
route you can't change the actual page
route declaratively yet we're gonna add
that into point one alright in - oh it
comes from the file name and if you want
to change it you have to do it in code
alright and I'll do that in a minute but
you can augment this so I can say I want
this to be ID question mark because
that's going to be optional and then I
want it to be handler question mark
because I want that to be optional as
well all right so what is optional mean
it
means that more than one route is
basically getting generated for this
page alright obviously I'm going to
match just index and then we have a
second one which is the default one
which removes it and then I'm specifying
an additional one which is index and
then ID and Handler if I didn't have the
question marks there index wouldn't
match anymore right because I would be
telling routing that it needs to have an
ID and it needs to have a handler all
right now this is just attribute routing
so you can do all the standard things I
can put a rack and straight on here
right I could say has to be and I an int
and I could reorder these if you prefer
to have the handler name first and then
have the ID delete this one then you
could do that right so now without doing
anything else that should be enough to
change this application so let's add a
new a customer I'll add myself back hit
enter right so I've got my new customer
let me clear the log and delete so this
time you can see now that I've gone to
customers ID and then delete all right
the whole thing just continued to work
that's the advantage of routing that's
why we built it all those years ago I
didn't have to change any other code all
I did was state that I wanted the route
to be different and then everything else
just continued to work right super super
super nice yeah so the question was what
if I want to change the method for the
forum or for what in the link you can't
change a method by a link right oh you
want to do a different HTTP method I'm
sorry so you want to handle something
other than delete other than post right
so yes you can do that you can't really
make HTML forms do anything other than
getting posts because HTML doesn't
support that but if you have like
JavaScript on this page and you want to
make a put request or a delete request
then all you would do is say on delete
async and we will just map that so we
don't get too opinionated out of the box
the default convention is look for
methods that start with on then look at
the current h2 be verb and look for that
here and then if there is a handler
specified look for that after that and
then optionally look for async and
that's it and if you don't like that
convention you can change it and there's
already a blog post from a dude in the
community who said I don't like all this
I just want verbs and you made it look
like web api too so we just has pose
get put blablabla and he just doesn't
that way no just works just fine so two
lines of code very very simple to change
all right so now how functional have we
gotten here we've got two the ability to
create a customer ok myself again that's
deja vu all right I can delete I can't
edit
but you can imagine what it looks like
I'm not gonna waste your time doing it I
have edit over here in this one and it
looks pretty much the same right so it's
just the same form as create except it
says in it and then the Edit code behind
looks exactly like you'd expect I bind
the customer I have my message like I
had before when I do a get I have to do
one get now right because I have to look
up the customer that I'm gonna edit so I
take in the ID I find them if it's null
I set a message it says hey I couldn't
find you and then I redirect you back to
the index otherwise I return the actual
page so you can edit the customer and
then after that on post when you've hit
Save Changes it looks like you'd always
see right check the model state if it's
about invalid return the page you can
see the errors update the entity
framework type go ahead and scroll save
say it was updated successfully look I
actually add a DB update concurrency
exception here and when it's finished
just redirect to the page all right
super super super simple
well what if you want to change I said
that you could change this URL but that
you couldn't do it declaratively so how
would you do that well you can do that
in card so let's go and do that I think
this is the app I was doing yep so if I
go after my startup and I go down to
here in my razor pages options I can
change the root directory as I said by
default it looks in pages if you don't
like the fact that there's a pages
folder you can just set that to nothing
and then we'll just look for razor pages
in the root of the app all right some
people like that but we decided to make
it that one by default so I can say
conventions I had paid route all right
so I can add a pager note it's not set
paid route you're still just adding
extra routes on top of the page not
changing the route route of the page
you're kind of adding an additional one
so I can add a page route my first thing
so it was a once is the page name so
this is page route relative so I want to
go
let's change customers slash index that
page two also or let's add a route not
change it so that it responds to all
customers Museum out of it alright so
now if I go to all customers at the root
of the app I want it to render customer
slush index let's see if that works well
just have five because I changed c-sharp
I have to recompile we compile and we
compiling so customers will still work
because I didn't change it I simply
added one all right but now I can say
all customers and that works as well now
I have multiple routes now for that
customers page right so what happens
when I ask you to generate well this
link here is generating right back to
customer list I asked it please give me
the link to customers flash index and
what did it do if I click on that it's
now using my custom one right so when
you add custom page routes they
basically go to the top of the list so
if you ask for generation it's always
going to use that one at the top okay
yeah well you absolutely can so the
question was around if it's named index
do you have to include the index so you
don't so if I just go slash customers oh
you mean when you're referring to pages
yes so the convention around making it
the default is for navigation is like
when the URL comes in when you refer to
the page you're basically pointing to
the file from the page root all right
now we don't excuse me right include the
extension because we know it's the HTML
but you have to point us to it's like
when you do views and you say find me
this view right there's kind of a search
hierarchy that goes on alright cool ER
what else oh let's get a page filter so
I said you could run filters if you
already have resource filters or all
filters they work with pages right there
don't just work you have to do anything
they will run when the action result
comes back from the page it's a resource
all your filters will run you can
authorize these with attributes if you
want you'll note I've got code here to
authorize a folder the accountmanager
folder because you can't get into that
unless you signed in and then to
authorize a specific page which is log
out now in to Oh
your only way to mark a folder is
authorizing code because there's no
attribute way too
stuff in a folder like where would you
put it right it goes on a class you
can't put it on a folder so you have to
write code to do that but when you're
authorizing a page you can if you want
to use attributes and I mean why
wouldn't you it's kind of nice so I
could say that customer deletes that
action or I could say customer new is
authorized I could go to its model and I
could come up here and I could just
decorate it with authorize just like you
would do anywhere else and now that that
particular page will require
authorization right because all that
does it's a marker that the authorized
filter that is in the pipeline looks for
right that's all it is it's very
straightforward
if we want to do a new one though let's
build a new one now incidentally we are
going to add a feature in 2.1 i hope
that will let you do this declaratively
for folders so what you'll be able to do
is you'll be able to go down to the view
imports and do something like this add
attribute authorize and you yeah if I
can type it authorize and you could put
in your policy in here or just do
something like that right and then that
would add the authorize attribute to
every page that that view imports
applies to all right so if you put the
view imports a different one inside
customers then would only apply to that
folder right so you get the whole
hierarchy thing that you get with view
imports and raiser which is kind of nice
by the way this is new and it works in
raiser views as well as razor pages the
app namespace directive will change the
namespace of the C sharp classes that
are generated from the razor files and
it honors the folders that the files are
in the razor files okay and so this way
your derived or your generated class
names that come from your razor files
can very easily end up in the same
namespaces as the c-sharp files of next
time that's not true today I don't know
if anyone's run into that where they try
and put a c-sharp file in the same
folder as a view and they wonder why
they can't see each other it's because
all views by default get put in a fixed
namespace it's like a spinet court views
or something well you can't change it
you can now right sorry that makes it
very very easy to find stuff which is
kind of nice all right let's add a
filter don't make my app not compile
there we go
I'll add a folder and call it filters
inside here I will add a class we'll
call it a logging page filter and I will
say I page filter and I will implement
that and so basically it looks like any
other filter that you've ever looked at
it has stages depending on what the
filter is targeting page filters target
pages so when the page handler is
selected you get a context that lets you
change stuff you can either log it out
you can override it you can tell it to
execute a different handler if you want
it's up to you when it's executing you
get one and then when it's executed you
get the outcoming action result and you
can modify it the way you normally would
ok who's ever written a filter for MVC
okay let's attack the same thing all
right
so use it you just add it to the MVC
filters collection with all the other
filters like it's not different just
throw it in there and it'll work alright
I'm not gonna bore you with that it does
- it does just work I can show you the
code and the other one if I go to the
startup alright so here's my filters
here's my page filter that I wrote I've
added it to my MVC options filters
collection and then that page filter
will run for his every single page that
I have yes the page filter does have a
sink support so I think you can do an i
async page filter yeah if you do now a
sink page filter then you get task based
methods instead of alright as I said you
can change the convention so if anything
in there offended you only because you
didn't like the fact that I called it a
handler or you didn't like the names of
the methods but you kind of like the
overall thing you can just change it say
pronoun who was one of the developers on
Razer pages
he has a github repo @preneur km
customizable page handlers and he has an
example there of using the page
conventions type to basically change a
whole bunch of stuff around how stuff is
found there's also a bunch of good
community blog posts about how to do
this as well there's at least two I know
of and if you watch the asp.net
community stand up everyone watch that
page make you stand up if you don't you
should it's great we featured a whole
bunch of those links in the last couple
of weeks so you can go to live a
spinette
if you've never seen this before to a
plug live a spinette we do a mostly
weekly show that goes for roughly half
an hour to an hour every week handsome
and John Galloway and myself and if I'm
not there then we have other people come
on
and we showcase community links we talk
about the content I give an update on
what we're doing that week and the team
and then we answer questions in YouTube
chat from people as well so if you're
interested in that whole archive of
we're doing about two years now the
whole archive of stuff is there and you
can see the next episode they had one
today when I wasn't there I think and
they're gonna do one next week which I
won't be there either because I'm on
holiday next week so all right some
things for v-necks that are coming we
want to add more conventions in box the
fusion the most visceral feedback we get
is like razor pages looks great but I
hate all these defaults I want to change
it to do this this isn't this and so if
we get enough of that feedback where
there are like factions of people that
want certain conventions and we might
just put some more conventions in the
box so you can just easily change them
right so yeah we'll have a default one
but these some other ones that you can
have in the box we want to add support
for page model properties and page
handle the parameter validation so what
I didn't say is that when you have a
page model property like customer you
can't put validation attributes directly
on the property there so you can't have
like string message have an input bound
to that and then have a required field
on message on your page model and it's
the same reason why you can't do it on
parameters in action methods right you
can't have like taking string message in
an action method and then put required
in the action method doesn't work it's
never worked we're going to make that
work in two point one all right because
people keep asking for a week finally
going to do it I talked about that
attribute and I talked about adding
support for attribute routing on pages
which would allow you to then use that
attribute to change the route of the
page directly on the page model or
inside the Razr file which would be
nicer you don't to do in c-sharp that's
it
please go off and try it out give us
your feedback over on the MVC repo
because it's just part of MVC so we can
make improvements to this in two point
one which we know will be coming at some
point in the future but please go off
and try this now as part of two oh it is
now in our TM and ready for all of you
to give it
I do give it a go so I'm done thank you
very much
you